my name is Ghana what we do
I'm not an economist so I am sure I have
not a very original dissolving a very
specific name position my position is
not so original that in deserve a
specific label no I think I am a social
democrat as we say in Europe I believe
in free market and I believe in
regulations I believe like Alec C de
Tocqueville or like bahama Const all or
like all the realtor editions of the
liberalism that liberalism means freedom
free market and so on but not the
freedom of the jungle of the savage
forest that it in it means it needs and
it means to some rules which American
you remember how at the beginning of
your modern history how accurate how
obsessive America was in forbidding
trusts abuses of dominant position how
you were in America so sharp in hunting
any excess or abuses of power everywhere
really there is a sour spirit in a way
of capitalism which could be which
should be not the worst thing in the
world it is the best compared to
communism compared to all that
capitalism is really the best but it has
to have a soul and we solve this spirit
was properly lost in the last 50 50
years
he meant what is happening today I mean
America this collapse this edge of abyss
in which you are this incredible greed
which led the country to this cows in
what it is today
so even when you are an apology's of
free market even when you believe in
free market because there is no
alternative system you cannot just
believe in it without any rules without
any regulation without any ethics the
nobility of America what America had
great in the past ages you might call it
the Puritanism ethics of Protestantism
whatever but it what America had great
was to combinate with free markets so
moral rules you lost that we lost that
maybe but you are the leading or well
the leading economy in the world these
last decades you lost the sense of these
combinations of this combination free
market plus article rules
Francie's something else there is a it
is a mix between this absurd crazy
indecent obscene grid-like in America
and also an excess of regulation we have
the to illness in France we have the the
loss of regular the lack of regulations
on the most sophisticated markets these
incredibly clever and sophisticated
inventions which were made by the market
man and which are made for the worst
it happens in human history that
sophisticate the most sophisticated
intelligence works for the world so we
had that also in France and we had the
reverse which was an excess of
regulation the 35 hours the overwhelming
strength of the state the excessive the
excess of burden which the very weight
of the state put on the shoulders of
every citizen so we have in France the
two problems which are competing to do
this recession I really believe that
what was called communism which is
probably dead but you have sometimes
from living Dead's
you have some dead who go out of the
grave you can you can see that in the
next time so communism was not at all a
school of solidarity it was not at all a
way of building Brotherhood it was a
contrary people all those who knew the
former Soviet Union knew how strong
whether hatred between the human beings
how how the social linked with with its
apparent peace which was imposed by the
policies of secret police and so on was
in really built on hatred the DNA the
material of the cells of the social link
and of communism was hatred of each one
toward each one this was the reality
on the contrary I do believe you have
some magnificant texts of the French
philosopher Emmanuel Levinas on that
that Monet as itself money the
abstraction of money abstraction the
abstracts of money the capacity which
money has to two separate things from
themselves and to make them circulate
between different people is a way of
building some civilization is a way of
making the every single man looking out
of his little corner of his roots or his
field and so on money opens the world
opens the minds opens with a society and
so it really created some some different
ways of thinking of thinking some
reflexes which could be which could be
terrible for example the lack of
individual initiative the quasi
impossibility of taking a decision I
remember one day just after the fall of
the Berlin Wall a lady in East Berlin
brilliant sharp smart Democrat having
fought during years and years against
communism and I remember so precisely in
a situation which is a private situation
I would not maybe gave the details here
she had to take a decision a decision as
a woman as a mother of family the woman
human decision yes or no this or that
and suddenly she burst into tears in her
apartment in front of me burst into
tears she told me I'm just enabled so I
said ok everybody can be enabled we have
all over the world some oblique people
some people who cannot decide and so on
and she explained to me the
day and that's was a great lesson that
maybe it was part of a psychology but
she explained to me why it was much more
than that the result in her mind the the
precipitation in her soul of the habits
created by the regime which was just
which has just been destroyed when you
have a state which decides everything
when you have police who who is always
awake when you have a big brother who
never sleep when you are the country of
the everlasting light watching
everything and everybody reflexes change
people human beings are human but they
can we are human first but there is a
you can have some quasi animal reflexes
which come back in some and or some
circumstances you see that in the
situation's of genocides human beings
don't look like themselves in a longer
overnight overnight a change 60 years of
communism was more than overnight and it
made the people change a little and it
changed in the sense of a real mental
and moral disease the communism the the
below of communism the the whole the
whole disaster of communism is known
materially we know the material disease
we have still to make to write the
history to write the history of the
moral deal
you